[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les grandes vacances d'été ont débuté la
semaine dernière en france et dans les
yvelines nous sommes au camping de
versailles à mes côtés une famille qui
vient d'auvergne pour passer à ses
vacances alors madame comment ça se
passe ses vacances ici il va très bien
profite de la région fait des visites
france miniature le château touahri donc
belle région malgré le temps oui
justement la météo n'est pas au beau
fixe comment vous faites mais on est
sous tente donc on fait avec et puis on
profite déjà de l'infrastructure du
camping de la piscine est tout ce qu
intérieure
[Musique]
comment ça se passe vraiment dans ce
camping on fait des activités ou qu'est
ce que vous faites 10 ans que le matin
nous prenant le petit déjeuner nous
partons pour une visite
aux alentours et puis aux attentes en
début d'après-midi nous sommes de retour
et nous faisons soit une petite sieste
nous allons à la piscine nous jouant aux
cartes
nous venions prendre un verre et ensuite
c'est l'heure de la douche et du repas
du soir des choses assez tranquille on
va dire justement va continuer vous
allez continuer votre partie de cartes
il y a environ entre 70 et 75 % de taux
d'occupation ici dans ce camping de
versailles
margot vous êtes la responsable est ce
que vous confirmez 70 à 75 %
d'occupation
oui tout à fait là surtout depuis le
début des vacances depuis le début du
mois de juillet on voit aussi que
certaines frontières se sont réouvertes
donc on à la clientèle internationale
qui est au rendez vous ici au camping
des clients internationaux des français
peut-être également tout à fait rond n'a
plus sur les hébergements insolites
une cliente elle-même francilienne
plutôt originaires d'île de france
mais après sur les emplacements plutôt
néerlandaise et allemande
la météo ça joue forcément sur le taux
d'occupation d'un lieu comme celui-là
tout à fait surtout hors vacances
scolaires où on va avoir des week-end
bien rempli avec le beau temps mais
après voilà on a aussi des activités à
faire par mauvais temps et la clientèle
est aussi au rendez-vous et bien occupé
on vous souhaite en tout cas un meilleur
temps la météo devrait à revenir au beau
fixe à partir de la fin de la semaine